Mí tình cách là tình quyền của ông, theo hạm thông tình Reuters,
Mí thời gian qua trên khai trên dịch quy mô lớn tại vùng biển Ké Me và phía đông thái vình dương.
Nhanh tri quái thoát đậu vốn bản mặt tủy mà nước này cho là ZOVNESUELA Hậu Thấn,
Washington đã huy động trên đậu cơ, tạo chiến và hàng nghìn biến sĩ,
nhắm vào ý nhất, mười bốn tàu bị nghi ngờ bốn lộ, kinh hơn sống mốt người khẹn mạc.
Tuy nhiên, nhiều gia đình đạn nhân cụng như chính phủ của họ trên bố, họ chỉ lấn rư rân và hoàn toàn không vì phạm pháo lần.
Tình bố phản đối cùng á đưa ra chỉ một ngày sau khi cáo quyền, nhìn quyền lên thậu quốc, ông vô cơ chất,
cũng kêu gọi Mỹ trong rất tắc cuộc tấn công tạo tuyền trong khu vực.
Những mạnh rằng việc xử dụng vụ lực về thường vòng dân xử không thể được viện linh,
bằng mục tiêu trống mặt tuy, và tình tương thủ viêm gặp lật pháp của tế.